over 90 percent of the world's Advanced
semiconductors are made in Taiwan and
semiconductors make our modern world run
everything from Autos to iPhones the
United States obviously can't let these
facilities fall into Chinese hands and
in fact they've communicated that if
there were a war the Americans would
destroy these facilities rather than
lose control of them but from China's
perspective if the United States is
going to cut off their access to these
facilities anyway
it might be better to strike Taiwan just
to level the playing field so this is
the quandary the U.S needs to preserve
its competitive advantages in
collaboration with allies but the
various steps that it could take to
preserve those advantages could
incentivize China to strike